The Prophet Muhammad
alayhi wasallam told us whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a similar house in Jannah.
And we know the great reward that will
not only be gained, but rather will fill
your grave after your death.
Whenever someone prays there, whenever
someone gives Shahada in the masjid,
whenever someone learns something in the
masjid. Yes. That will be something that
you will have on your scale.
[Music]
There's one thing we can all agree on.
That the universe
is regular, stable,
uniform.
The extent to which it allows life to
exist within it.
From every
small atom
to the largest of celestial spheres,
we see incredible goal-directedness
within
the cosmos. Now, the question is,
what is the best explanation for that?
Is it a source of knowledge
or is it a lack thereof?
This is the question that must be asked.
Is it a source of knowledge
or is it a lack thereof?
Another question that could be asked
is that did something come from nothing?
Is it conceivable, intelligible, or
plausible for something to come from
nothing? That the universe came from
nothing.
Did the universe generate and cause
itself?
Well, to suggest that the universe was
generated or caused itself is tantamount
to saying
that a mother gave birth to herself.
And to suggest that there's more than
one ultimate source of being,
more than one necessary existence
is tantamount to saying
that you can have more than one mother
to one sole child.
Therefore,
it is clear
that monotheism, the idea of one source
that is the foundation
for everything that exists,
is the only reasonable conclusion.
Another question that must be asked
is what is the purpose of life?
What is the purpose of life?
Imagine going to work.
You don't know who your boss is.
You don't know what your role is.
You don't know what you're doing there.
But here we are
in the career of life
and we don't know what our purpose is.
The purpose of life
is to align the finite with the
infinite.
The purpose of life
is to submit to the lawgiver.
is to submit to the ultimate source of
all creation. That's why
prophets and messengers were sent a full
time.
Abraham,
Moses,
Jesus,
and for us, the final prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
And these prophets came
to expound on this truth,
to tell people to submit to God.
And they came
with an evidence for their prophethood.
As for the Prophet Muhammad,
his evidence
is that he came with a preserved
religion.
The Quran is preserved in a way that no
other ancient book is.
There's a falsification test within the
Quran
challenging humanity
to find a contradiction within it.
Challenging humanity to try and produce
a chapter like it.
And the prophet of Islam made
predictions that were so frequent and so
precise
that no other figure in human history
made them. For example,
he told us that the Roman Empire and the
Persian Empire would both fall to the
Muslims.
Now, according to Barnaby Rogerson, who
is a historian,
non-Muslim historian, he said that the
similitude of the Arabs at that time
taking over the Persian and Roman Empire
is the same
as Eskimos taking over Russia and
America. Imagine what kind of a wild
prediction this is.
And this is one of many predictions that
I would say I don't have time to expound
here.
The question is, what does atheism have
to offer?
Atheism has no explanatory force
whatsoever.
Atheism is a negation. Atheism has no
ontological status.
Atheism cannot
describe or explain morality,
rationality, consciousness.
Atheism brings nothing to the table.
Hey, you. Are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masjid, a Dawah center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So, that makes the reward
even greater. So, give generously and
Allah Azzawajal will give you even more.